we could talk about Christmas for hours
but I'm distracted by the makings of a
cocktail cocktail at Christmas everyone
[Applause]
okay well I like to give Britain a
little tip every now and again so you
need to find yourself a sheath right now
this is if you go to the really posh
cocktail bars you get these incredible
ice cubes that they hand-carved oh no no
no we go get a waterbomb right and we
just split it and we peel it off and we
get a lovely round they do it the posh
places then we're gonna make a Christmas
Negroni Christmas Negro knee
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Negroni I won't eat think of it as
medicine right okay if you've got every
one of us has someone a bit boring a bit
sort of dodgy come in to the Christmas
party there's always one so then what
you do is you take this Negroni aka
medicine medicine right and it turns
people that are a bit problematic and
boring into interesting people 20 mils
of Campari
20 mils of vermouth Russell which we've
sent it with a little cinnamon and
Christmas fair yes and then we have a
little gin a little bit of Clementine to
get you guys are you ready for this I'm
like come on man if you don't become
more interesting I don't know what's
going to happen okay one pass it down is
like school like a Christmas Carol and
we are Scrooge because like a Merry
Christmas
six-hundred Tiny Tim's okay oh come on
oh I'm the world changing lead a judge
of whether or not it's delicious
no I like that it has just enough
Christmas in it here's the thing
no that's very good that's right you
want sit you want sit home drank from
this side so you could drink from that
side you can just another side you see
what you think is this like feeding a
gremlin after midnight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
going a to be fast you can this is a
fairly simple sport like your menses go
out to start endure at the finish
closing your eyes and pull like a dog
yeah so that phrase who came up with
that is that a phrase everywhere now in
Ireland yeah yeah like you would be
walking down the street there and in
Dublin or somewhere in the village it's
time for Party Pieces everyone Catherine
what have you brought us but I found
this very intimidating and I think I
think I can make a noise like a baby cry
it's a party
like your newborn crying okay I did only
try this out today
[Music]
[Applause]
classic underselling it meant some money
it's forced to dredge that up I wish my
my little boy was that quiet when he
returned guy Pierce the pride of
Australia the pride of Australia what
are you going to be well in the spirit
of Priscilla I thought perhaps I'd give
you some of the Opera you series gonna
talk all the bus you're gonna sit at the
top of the box Aria okay
look I'm a little croaky I'm croaky of
throat pop moment okay that we'll see if
we can remember okay okay
Foley Foley delivery of a Norquist Oh Oh
abandon Hara in questa Popolo so desire
you kill an open heart alerta Sempron
while VD vole of your knee open sir
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow baby crying when I do that to him at
home though the party peace pressure has
rolled down the couch okay keira
knightley this is good wait for this I
can play my teeth can play
raindrops keep falling on my hair I mean
I can play anything you want but like
much going with raindrops that you've
chosen that songs I'm wearing a jacket
where I can't quite bend my arms so I
don't quite think I think this mic will
pick it up okay fine okay wait a minute
Oh haven't done this in a while so this
is just to remind you this is performed
on her teeth take it away yeah
[Applause]
that's
recently tweeted some letters these are
genius these are letters you wrote to
your parents frog from sunny summer camp
yeah okay so the one is the first one's
kind of a form letter so it's hi from
camp do your mom and dad how are you in
hell
yesterday I realized that my tent was
full of morons these really annoying
kids are by tomorrow excruciatingly
boring class begins I can't wait to go
home please have me some mad magazines
I'd like that
lovely Miranda yes the kids are okay if
you get used to them this this contains
drawings and also it's on Garfield
papers you know he's taking it seriously
yes dear family hi remember me I'm the
kid you ditched in the woods for a bunny
we hardly ever go to Mass well I go
every Sunday
here's a picture to remind you of me you
jumping off a building
I did it was the performance of my life
I'm not proud of it as an adult and if
my kids ever ask about it I'll deny it
but I faked a spinal injury there was a
kid who hurt his back and got to go home
and I went today I was alone with a
friend of mine I threw myself on the
floor I pretended I couldn't feel my
legs and I was rushed to the hospital
and I had to keep up this performance
all summer and I had a fake limp and I
went to I had x-rays at Bellevue
Hospital in New York City and but I went
home any you're kind of we were saying
your sexual awakening was was was a
two-dimensional sexual awakening it's
true I was wanting to be you know I was
like what you know who would that your
first crushes and and and I did I loved
the Lion King when I was younger and I
had a with Nala
[Applause]
look at her face she's so sweet
you can sing really well that's wrong is
it you like Maid Marian as well yes that
is true she's a fox though very low I
know this he's packin you know you were
very successful in this country and much
beloved but now you see kind of the
world discovering you and but like but
now do you see you in things like Vogue
and all these things doing high fashion
shoots and stuff like is this what you
dreamt of this very high at last I love
my job very much I love it I love going
to work which is I know very lucky yeah
yeah but the other stuff is a bit
embarrassing what do you have to do it
do you have to kind of rock off you have
to do it I think I've been sort of
persuaded to do it I definitely know do
you know if you have to do it yeah we
don't have to do it but do they say but
they know you have to yeah
cuz I don't know that I do but then
suddenly find yourself it's important
tries it yeah yeah they say that yeah
they do say that a lot I said you had to
do this right yeah even I've been told I
have to do this
definitely one even made with all they
out
this is genuinely one of the things
that's really enjoyable to do Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you